obviously mobilizing EU funds is
fundamental but not sufficient we also
require and this is the second point an
enabling framework to ensure that
further public and private investment
happen in that context this year we will
finalize the climate change objectives
of the EU taxonomy we will also present
a renewed sustainable finance strategy
and an EU standard for green bonds the
upcoming review of our five fiscal
framework will include a reference to
sustainable public investment in the
context of the quality of public finance
and I am looking forward to the debate
after the communication on how to treat
sustainable investment within the EU
fiscal rules of course preserving
safeguards against risk to that
sustainability just look to Australia
there's an urgency to act at the heart
of the green tea land this transition to
the future is the just transition
mechanism here it's about mobilizing at
least 100 billion euro of investment it
will help cities and regions with less
capacities to catch up turning
environmental economic and social
challenges into opportunities and
creating new sustainable and
future-oriented chops
the instrument will rely on a 7.5
billion euro of fresh funds from the you
budget let me be clear that this is on
top of our m FF proposal the shirt
pillar will provide subsidized loans to
the public sector for non bankable
projects the public sector loan facility
with the European Investment Bank will
seek to mobilize between 25 and 30
billion euro it will for example finance
energy efficiency measures including the
renovation of affordable housing
hospitals and schools let us not forget
that poles pollution and economic
activity have no borders
now all the elements on the table and
it's time to conclude the MFF we have no
time to waste
if we want to deliver results for the
citizens or again in a nutshell we
provide climate cash in order to avoid a
climate crash the transition fund is as
mentioned in particular geo the an
element that comes on top of the
allocations for cohesion and for
agriculture it will represent 7.5
billion and it is a specific instrument
that puts cohesion policy in the sense
of helping regions that depend too much
that depend mainly are almost mainly on
industries and activities that a carbon
related and that will be massively
affected in right track minimizing the
impact of this transition in their
economic economy and in their social and
the job situation
in terms of of governance so the each
member state will have to have the
identification of the territories then
to describe the transition process and
to show its consistency with the
national energy and climate plan and for
each of the identified territories the
combination of instruments and funds
that are supposed to deliver the
strategy that has been agreed upon